the surge is coming says Trump a stark
warning about what lies ahead for the
United States this is going to be a very
painful very very painful two weeks when
you look and see at night the kind of
death that's been caused by this
invisible enemy it's it's incredible is
that the food it's vicious
president Trump has repeatedly compared
coronavirus to the flu consistently
downplaying the severity of what he now
calls a plane but data presented by his
experts has forced a rethink in their
estimates they had between 1.5 million
and 2.2 million people in the United
States are coming to this virus without
mitigation yet through their detailed
studies and showing us what social
distancing would do what people what
would happen if people stayed home what
an extraordinary thing this could be if
every American followed these it's those
shocking numbers that have made Donald
Trump climbed down from his aspiration
of reopening America in less than two
weeks realizing the gravity has taken
Trump a long time he rejects criticism
of a slow response know how bad it was
all you have to do is look at what was
going on in China it was devastation and
well yeah look at the numbers from China
those initial numbers coming out from
China but you know I read an article
today which was very interesting they
say we wish president Trump would give
more bad news
get bad news I'm not about bad news I
want to get people hope as tests and
confirmed cases accelerate the message
from the White House has become clear
social distancing is working but to save
hundreds of thousands of lives it cannot
stop Amanda Walker's Sky News Washington